[موسيقى] زوار [الموسيقى]
بعد تذوق الماء ، فإن
أول شيء ذكروه هو
أنه سلس حقًا لأن العديد من
البلدان ليس لديهم
مياه الصنبور الناعمة ، لذا فإن
أهم مصدر في المجر هو
الماء
ونحن أغنى بلد في  أوروبا
في الماء ، لذلك هذا هو السبب في أننا
جلبنا موضوع المياه إلى معرض دبي ،
لذا فإن معرض الزارا
والماء بأكمله مبني حول المياه ، وتكون
ذروة الرحلة هي أنه يمكنك في الواقع
تجربة ثلاث مياه معدنية مختلفة من
المجر بحيث  لديك طعم حقيقي
في فمك يمكنك أن تشعر أنه يمكنك
تذوقه ولهذا السبب قمنا بإحضار شريط أكوا
إلى جناحنا
[موسيقى]
لذلك لدينا ثلاث مياه معدنية مختلفة
هنا لتذوقها من المجر ،
وكلاهما كل هذه  هي
مياه معدنية طبيعية
وأولها يسمى copiaris 383 وهي
مياه قلوية طبيعية مع معدن مثالي
ومحتوى تدقيق وهذا الماء
عمره أكثر من آلاف السنين
والماء  يعود تاريخ الرواسب نفسها إلى أكثر من 10000
عام وهي مفيدة حقًا للمعدة
لعمليات التمثيل الغذائي وتساعد
البشرة على تجديد الشعر
وتجديده ، وبسبب محتوى حمض السيليك المعدني ،
فإنها تعمل أيضًا على تجديد
الخلايا
والثانية هذه  واحد يسمى
الانسجام
، وهو أيضًا مياه معدنية طبيعية قادمة
من المجر ، إنها تأتي من ستة
ينابيع ماترا مختلفة
وتساعد على تعاون
العقل والروح ، إنها جيدة حقًا
لرفاهيتك العقلية وتنشط نفسك على
الفور الثالثة التي نوفرها
يوجد هنا في أكوابار لدينا يسمى
brielle ، إنه مشابه حقًا للأول
من حيث فوائده ، فهو
ماء قلوي طبيعي بقيمة ph 8.3
ويحتوي أيضًا على محتوى وحدة مثالي
ومحتوى معدني ولكن يمكن
استهلاكه بشكل غير محدود مقارنة بـ
الاثنان الآخران اللذان يمكن
استهلاكهما مثل مرة واحدة في اليوم ،
لذا فإن هذين الأولين ناعمين وسلس على حد سواء
، ستشعر
وكأنه يتأرجح  من خلال حلقك يكون هذا
ناعمًا وسلسًا في حين أن الثالث يكون
أكثر ترابيًا قليلاً وقاسيًا قليلاً ،
ولن أقول إنه قاسي ولكنه
أصعب من الاثنين الآخرين ،
وكلاهما جميعهم يتمتعون
جميعًا بمذاق فريد حقًا  لكنهما مختلفتان
[موسيقى]
في معرضنا ،
نود أن نعرض
تاريخ
المياه المجرية ،
يمكنك الحصول على بعض الأمثلة على كيفية استخدامنا
للمياه في علم الأحياء الحديث
وكيف استخدمناه منذ بضع مئات من
السنين أيضًا  علاجات الأحياء
[الموسيقى]
الشيء المثير للاهتمام أيضًا
في الجناح المجري
هو القبة
حيث يمكنك مشاهدة فيديو مثير جدًا
عن حياة الماء
وهناك أيضًا حمام سباحة خاص جدًا
[موسيقى]